did you see the article about uh what's
going on in la right now because you
know all these guys that are saying this
stuff sometimes they say these
unrealized games defund the police it's
a good idea and then they're like oh
[ __ ] we didn't say the republicans said
defund the police no no you came up with
defunded police yes and now they're all
increasing their budget to hire cops
because in la did you see what happened
in l.a at the grove like what they have
around the grove did you did you see
what the type in la grove fence did you
see what the lapd put out for travelers
coming to l.a like don't wear anything
flashy if somebody if somebody tries to
rob you yeah try to negotiate them just
give them what they're gonna look at
this this is cnn
famous la shopping center adds barbed
wire like fence to deter smash and grabs
wow this is this isn't we're talking
about cnn here look at this this doesn't
make any sense businesses are worried
today in l.a fyi yesterday somebody sent
the story saying uh a famous uh look at
that look at that that's crazy yeah that
doesn't make any sense by the way the
wire fences
the apple store
from robbery
did you pull up the apple store in
portland after that watch this the wire
fencing in place didn't fully deter a
robbery at the grove on november 22nd
when a group of 18 to 20 looters used
sledgehammers and an electric bicycle to
smash into the complex nordstrom after
hours they managed to steal at least
five thousand of merchandise and cost
fifteen thousand dollars in damages
through police later recover merchandise
arrested three people in connection with
the burglary the video somebody sent me
a video yesterday so check this out guy
walks in takes stuff he's at walmart
they can't say anything to him he just
walks out he's not running out he just
walks out then he walks out he ties his
shoelaces outside
in front of the stairs you're
you you just stole you're supposed to
run that's the protocol he's dying in
shoelaces
i'm not going to get arrested home so
someone said oh people are
leaving l.a i said dude you have not
seen the exodus california's about to
experience it hasn't started yet people
think it started because elon you know
all these guys have joe rogan
yet just wait just wait
uh to see what happens there but uh yeah
so these policies that uh you're talking
about by the way i want to look at the
stock act that came up with some people
are talking about that aoc has money and
all this other stuff u.s news did an
article saying what are congress members
trading
uh in 2013 a
amendment to the stock act came up made
some changes clouding the transparency
and
accessibility congress members financial
transactions most notably
removed the requirement for electronic
filing in a searchable sortable database
of transactions however one useful
aspect of the legislation which requires
members to publicly report
financial transactions and stocks bonds
and other assets within 45 days yeah
that remains which is good this is why
people know what pelosi owns but but
there's still people that are skirting
that like republican tommy tupperball
the ex-football coach he he refuses he
refuses to admit what he sells all the
time like he got caught uh selling
alibaba stock months after he sold it
now he's got uh by the way for people
that don't want to look it up tommy
tubble has some massive short puts on
both apple microsoft and uh first
quarter of 2022 i think uh
became a true three trillion out of
companies if you believe if you believe
tommy tupperware he thinks that the
first quarter of 2022 is going to be
brutal
i share that opinion so this is
incredible you share that opinion i i
have the opinion i also fair disclosure
had the opinion that bitcoin was going
to run up by now but i think it's going
to run up in the first quarter followed
by a massive sell-off on crypto um
tech stocks how bad how bad do you think
it's going to be 20 20 30 30 so you
think bitcoin is going to drop to what
25 30. my prediction bitcoin hits over a
hundred thousand and drops back to where
it is today
so okay yeah so it's you're not saying
it's going to drop to 20 or 15 or 30 or
anything like that i mean it could i
think it's going to be a massive i think
there's too much money in it right now
yeah but after the run-up i think the i
think it could go from 150 back to 50.
yeah that's not that's not uh that's not
something that's going to move the the
uh the long play guys what does a
pom say nearly 85 of uh bitcoin owners
never sell their bitcoin they keep it
they just sit on it so these are not
guys that are churning and burning of
course the other 15 is just buying it as
a absolutely stock and they're you know
pumping down but many of the true
believers are hanging on to it why do
you think the first quarter of 2022 is
going to be so bad or are the holiday
revenues not going to be what they
normally are is that what the idea is
here like why on earth i mean it could
start to be happening now i i obviously
no one can time the market you know i
mean i just think that senators seem to
do it pretty good well that's true uh
they're talented they're smart they have
degrees from carter's columbia
university they seem to do pretty good
yeah it's it's a different kind of a
world they're living in so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]